Well,
after months of ferocious
fighting in Beirut,
the chief of Russia's
private army,
Wagner, saying his fighters are exhausted
and will withdraw.
Move, which was actually Moscow.
We will be leaving
Bermuda and the Russian defense
ministry will be responsible for it.
We're leaving
two field camps to train and rest.
Precaution claims
to control all of Mahmoud,
which the Ukrainians dispute.
He also acknowledges losing around
20,000 fighters
in the brutal months long campaign.
Even as the U.S.
and Ukraine say
the figures are much higher,
possibly up to 100,000
despite the alleged victory in Bermuda.
In a bold comment,
Prigozhin says
Vladimir Putin's
war is not achieving
its core objective of weakening Ukraine.
Comes from the military here with
how did we demilitarize it?
Now it turns out that we,
on the contrary,
have militarized Ukraine.
We have almost no guidance issued.
I think that
Ukrainians today
are one of the strongest armies yet.
Subscale
Prigozhin has long
been attacking Russia's elites,
accusing them of being corrupt, lazy
and not involved in the war here.
Now, he fears continuing
losses on
the battlefield
could lead to a revolution in Russia.
Future, more disappointments.
All of this can end like in 1917,
with a revolution
when first the soldiers rise up
and after that, their loved ones rise up.
All this as the war is increasingly
affecting Russia's homeland.
Russia's defense ministry today
releasing video of what it says
was a failed attack on a Russian warship
using unmanned speedboats.
Ukraine has not commented
on the incident.
And after the brazen cross-border raid
by anti-Putin Russian fighters,
which Ukraine says it was not involved
in, but Russia blames on Kiev
vowing revenge. The borders minister.
We will continue to respond
to such actions
by Ukrainian militants promptly.
An extremely harshly.
But Prigozhin says the attack shows
the Russian military
is incapable
of protecting the country's border,
echoing the putting
their egos of ship,
sabotage and reconnaissance forces
calmly into Russia and March,
uploading videos
driving their tanks, armored
infantry vehicles.
Where's the safeguard
that they will not enter Moscow?
And, of course, and
we've been reporting so much about that
ongoing feud between Yevgeny
Prigozhin and the Russian defense
minister, Sergei Shoigu.
So it was certainly no surprise
to have Prigozhin
criticize Shoigu,
but this time he also called for Shoigu
to be replaced.
However, also in light of
that incident in Belgorod.
There are a lot of people
who are asking in Russia
how exactly it was possible
that the military
was not on scene
as that cross-border
raid was taking place.
And of course,
now with that fire
that we've been learning about in Moscow,
you can feel that
there is some nervousness
creeping in
as to whether security
is guaranteed there.